we're thrilled to have here kicking off
our final hour here on this Tuesday two
days after episodes five and six went
down there's four more to go
he is a a champion of the Chicago Bulls
three times over and was also on the
championship team as with the Spurs the
year after the last dance he is from NBC
Sports Chicago Bulls studio analysts
will Purdue how are you will wrist I'm
doing very well thank you and let me
make it clear
winning never gets old I bet it never
does right I bet it doesn't what's it
been like for you to relive it through
this documentary you know it's it's
brought back a lot of memories but also
a lot of emotions you know it's almost
kind of been you know a little reunion
for a lot of the players as we've all
been reaching out to get former
teammates on podcast and zoom calls and
things like that so that part's been
nice but it's also been a vivid reminder
of you know that people have been
watching this and I've been watching it
just like everybody else I didn't get a
pre-screening view of it but it's you
know it's been a reminder of you know
some of the sacrifices we had to make
the drama that was involved some of the
tension you know I always kind of
chuckle everybody's like oh man you guys
just kicked the Pistons ass we're like
just because it was fluoro doesn't mean
it was easy I mean every game you know
came down to the wire so it wasn't that
easy but just it's been interesting to
kind of for me is to watch the response
to what people are hopefully learning
more about Michael Jordan as he's pulled
back the curtain but you know even after
episodes I think three and four when
they showed Michael hugging that trophy
after we won a championship at 91 it
kind of brought us here to my eye
because it was emotional you know
everything that we had gone through and
especially the fact that that was a
three-year journey just to get to that
championship in 91 - first of all get
past the Pistons and also beat the big
bad Lakers who at that time had allowed
I think 11 championships for their
organization where we had none well I
don't know if it was you who said it in
the documentary will or is one
of your teammates saying that watching
Jordan hugged that trophy for the first
time and get emotional and cry was kind
of jarring to you as teammates because
Jordans only emotions that he showed
were intensity anger not much outward
love or crying emotion did that resonate
with you is that you who said it and
that documentary I can't recall off the
top of my head yeah it was I said that
that was really a surprise to us
because really the only emotions we had
seeing from Michael was you know
frustration and anger because of the
inability to beat Detroit I mean dude he
was not happy when he lost it anything I
mean anything that's how competitive he
was and you know the inability to get
back good past Detroit in 89 the
inability to get past Detroit 90
I mean he listened to be honest he
always pointed his finger at himself
first because as good as he was he
always started he gets better that's
what made our practices so competitive
but he also expected everybody else to
answer the bell and that was the hard
part I mean I think you can talk to a
lot of guys I'll be the first to admit I
never questioned whether I could play in
the NBA when I got drafted just when I
got drafted to the Bulls I questioned
after the first couple practices in
training camp in 1988 for the 88 89
season I was like damn I don't know you
know I got to do something
you know it's not just gonna be my work
ethic that's gonna gain the respect of
this guy it's gonna take a lot more than
that so what was it like being his
teammate we'll it was tough because of
the expectations and I I say this you
know nothing that Michael didn't
understand how good he was but I think
at times you know he felt that listen if
you work as hard as me you can be as
good as me and I think sometimes you had
to like say hey no that's not how it
works man I mean they're just certain
people are more talented than others
period so you know we're all out here
busting our ass we're all out here
working our you know butts off because
we want to get
as well but you know at some point you
have to learn that you know we as
players have certain limitations but you
have to be comfortable with those
limitations but you also have to trust
that hey we're going to put in the time
we're going to put in the effort and
we'll be ready for the you know for you
when you decide to trust us a lot John
Paxson obviously Steve Kerr I mean even
I was just watching we're doing some
stuff here in Chicago where we're
playing all the 89
I'm sorry 98 series and in Game seven
against the Pacers I mean he actually
had a couple you know late-game passes
to loop along with who'd knocked down a
couple you know baseline jump shots
those were things that he didn't do
early on in his career inside six
minutes he's like listen I got this
whereas still Jackson kind of chipped
away instead of if you really want to
win a championship they're really the
only way that's going to happen is if at
some point you show your vulnerability
and allow yourself to trust your
teammates well and and then we saw
obviously Paxson was the one who was
open to take care of the Lakers for for
that first championship that you're
referring to and then we all saw who
made the the dagger shot against the
Suns in this past weekend I remember her
specifically I think you were I remember
correctly weren't you in LA during that
91 championship did I not see you there
covering you definitely did not see me
there covering I was I was in stat now
in New York as the cub reporter for the
Staten Island Advance only dreaming of
being on SportsCenter one day which I
was for the fright for you believe
you're 99 Spurs championship and I'm
still right I'm still holding I'm still
holding my breath for those moments I
I'm gonna pop up with hair like Chris
Fowler had this past weekend and Dan
Patrick's apparently gonna have next but
you know in terms of again being his
team I got will Perdue here on the Rich
Eisen show did your fault I'm right you
you had a fight with Jordan in a
practice correct that's a true story
so let me what happened by two things we
won I apologize but I actually remember
talking to you I work for ESPN radio
during the Lakers yeah Celtics final
maybe that's it sure there you go so you
know that's the other
fifty-five they're looking at basketball
I still feel like I'm in my 20s I never
looked at it as a real job so everybody
I came across I always honestly I
apologize I always thought was older
than maybe because the real job it's all
good man but we had a situation in
practice and that's what I mean the
intensity I mean we got in arguments all
the time and I always clarify listen
when you want to talk about the NBA
there's no such thing really as an NBA
fight every once in a while you saw what
was truly a fight but NBA fights are
more like skirmishes you push a guy you
know you get in the guy's face you point
a finger you know
NBA a fight is described as you know so
many steps in the middle and you're like
all right now's my chance you reach
around a guy throw a cheap shot because
the other guy can't reach back at you
because there's somebody in between you
but we had an episode in practice where
we were running the high frequency plays
of our opponents and I still to this day
I'm pretty sure it was the Milwaukee
Bucks and the one thing we were trying
to emphasize was is that Milwaukee was
going to continue to run Michael off a
bunch of screens in the hopes that the
last six minutes of the game he'll be
fatigued both mentally and physically
and we'll think twice about eight I'm
really gonna look to attack the hoop and
maybe start settling for jump shots and
because he's fatigued be a little short
and not be able to get to the free-throw
line and get points there so we kept
running this one play where I was
setting screens on them got pretty good
shots as they said in the day I was
laying some wood and one time I hit him
pretty hard he bounced up off the floor
he said listen you do that again I'm
going to punch you he was a little more
colorful language so as soon as that
happened Johnny Baca with the assistant
coach that set up our defensive schemes
immediately yelled running again so I
thought to myself hey man if I'm gonna
get punched by this guy which I still
didn't think he was gonna do it I'm
gonna make sure I get my money's worth
so I made sure it was an illegal screen
I don't think I ever stopped I just ran
right through him knocked his ass to the
ground he got up and immediately just
turned around and hauled off and swung
at me and I was able to duck just enough
so we didn't get a square shot that face
but kind of hit me across the side of
the temple but again it wasn't like it
turned into a debacle you know once I
realized what happened I kind of started
to step towards him Eddie Neely who was
on to see
him at the time grab you from behind and
just kind of said Oh big boy that's
probably not a good idea and then the
other thing was we just you know settle
down continue to practice wasn't like
they separated practice at all and
that's it we're done you guys got to go
in a room and a [ __ ] out we just kept
practicing that stuff happened a lot
more than people think
now the actual punch that that wasn't
didn't happen a lot I know they're gonna
talk a lot about this upcoming week
regarding Steve Kerr and MJ but there
were skirmishes all the time because you
got to remember the guys in the second
team we were fighting against the guys
in the first team trying to get more
minutes trying to replace those guys you
know trying to justify our position on a
team so the game for us I don't want to
say they were easy but it was refreshing
when we played games on those Bulls
teams because of how competitive and how
hard we went out of the practice will
Perdue here on the Rich Eisen show did
you have to have that environment you
think in order to win as much as you did
I mean is that was it necessary for you
to have that edge and in potential anger
or and dislike will about the answer's
no because you know as you pointed out I
got traded to San Antonio for Denis and
ended up winning a championship there
but they had a totally different culture
a totally different atmosphere but yet
you had that competitiveness you didn't
necessarily have that anger you didn't
necessarily have the aggressiveness but
that was Michael Jordan that was led by
Michael Jordan that's how Michael Jordan
approaches the game and you know I know
a lot of people are getting that
opportunity to see Michael and
apparently episode 7 they open up a lot
of big can of worms because I know the
producer has been out there talking
about I'm really surprised Michael what
allowed us to do seven and eight the way
we did it because apparently it doesn't
paint a very good light against him but
guys we played with them we understood
them it took a little while but you
adjusted and you understood but at the
end of the day I always say if you want
to understand who Michael Jordan was and
if you want to know the definition of a
hard-ass but a guy that wanted to win at
all costs go back and look at his Hall
of Fame speech that was Michael Jordan
being sank fell'd thanking those that
doubted him to help motivate them
throughout
career well you know what the speech
that I prefer to to you know because
that that's the one where you know
obviously the crying Jordan but there
were people who also took a lot of
offense as to what he said his speech at
Kobey's memorial was beautiful just
beautiful just a beautiful touching
tribute from the goat to somebody who
looked up to Michael and I think is the
only one who's been well I waited fair
to see in his area code of
competitiveness of red ass of that sort
of Mamba mentality right will would you
say yeah cuz you saw during his time as
once he became the man in LA because
Kobe even admits it you know when I
first got there I tried to be a man but
everybody remembers me is the guy
shooting their balls against Utah the
playoffs right but he eventually became
Jordan esque not necessarily and his
accomplishments but as an attempt to
follow in Michael shoes but also if you
talk about the red asses the the
hardcore I mean how many guys came
through the Lakers organization that
he's that he spit that he chewed up and
spit out it didn't get along with him
couldn't understand the mentality
weren't willing to make the sacrifices
their play as hard regardless of how
good they were
it didn't last very long with the Lakers
he was very similar and it was kind of
interesting to hear him you know talk
about how he reached out how Michael
made the offer and you know how he
referred to Michael is an older brother
and they got that I think they got that
that part about him just in January of
this year
and then to hear Michael talk about how
he was a younger brother at you know the
Memorial few minutes left here with will
Purdue NBC supports Chicago and former
teammate of Michael Jordan just three
championship seasons with Michael
right here on the Rich Eisen show so you
you you were there obviously when
Michael retired for the first time by
the way I was there as a cub reporter
for the northwestern School of
Journalism I was in the Berto Center
that day and I just remember how what a
huge gathering it was and what a stunner
it was what was it like from your
position because again that's a preview
of what we're gonna see this weekend
well same thing I heard
of it but you're like listen the guys in
his prime
he's not gonna retire I understand
what's going on you know and what's
happening with his father I know how
emotional that is but we also felt that
you know with the loss of his father
where else would he want to be but on
the basketball floor you know to honor
his father but when it happened we mean
I'd same thing I was actually not at the
Berto Center I watched on TV and I was
just you know it was one of those things
that once I heard it was a reality I
still couldn't believe it until I
actually saw it and then once I saw it
and he mouthed those words I just
remember sitting there like holy yeah
and I was just like you know where do we
go and it was then it was kind of like
that moment of where do we go from here
well what was it like without him in
that season well we had to reestablish
our identity and you know huge credit
goes to Horace Grant to Scottie Pippen
and more so to Bill Cartwright to
maintain that edge but talk about how
competitive we still could be how good
we could be and you know we ended up
with in 55 games because it was I'm not
saying it was easier fulfill but you
know we kept hearing the same thing we
got to play with our chip on their
shoulder we got to show these guys that
we can play without Michael it's your
duty to yourselves you know blah blah
blah blah blah one of it I make it in
comparison to Doc Rivers home friends
with nearly one coach of the year when
he was with the Orlando Magic when they
went 41 and 41 but doc said he gave the
same speech for 82 games those guys in
the other locker room don't respect you
all right let's go
it was kind of like still was using the
same thing every game play with a chip
on your soul to prove to them that
they're wrong show them how good you are
without Michael Jordan did you think
Michael quit on you and that's a tough
question asked because we all know the
emotions that was going on with him and
his dad and but but he was he was he was
everything did you think he could did
the team think he quit on on them and
you know absolutely not it's I thought
that he was looking for another
challenge
quite honestly and he found it in
baseball and you know he talked about
his love for baseball or the youngster
and I don't want to say he got bored
with basketball but I think he you know
Jordan rules had come out there was a
crack in the armor it wasn't just be
like Mike there were a lot of things you
know the gambling and the book and
everything else and I think that I don't
want to say it got to him but I think
that part of him was was tired of the
drama that became being Michael Jordan
he just wanted to be a basketball player
I think he also realized that because he
wasn't an activist he caught heat for
that you know he wasn't Muhammad Ali he
caught heat for that no he just wanted
to be a basketball player huge saw last
week he said hey if that selfish and
maybe it is but I'm sorry but that's who
I am
I just wanted to eliminate all the
distractions and be a basketball player
I think through distractions I don't
want to say they became too much but I
also believe that he wanted to try
something new and there weren't any
distractions in baseball at the time the
only distraction what people were you
know wondering can he do this will man I
could talk to you the rest this hour but
I've you know I know you got other stuff
to do and I appreciate the call well
this is great this you you're you're
you're terrific recounting all this
stuff and you know I appreciate you
taking the time to lend to lend a little
bit more perspective here on on the show
to my viewers and listeners well I
appreciate you having me I know I'll say
I'm slightly aggravated it's the first
time I've ever been on your show but it
is an honor and thank you well we'll do
it again we'll do it again we'll this is
not our last dance how does that sound
hey as long as you lead I'm good okay
that's it and if you try that one more
time I'm gonna hit you
okay well ring a bell okay you take care
you got it right thank you God I will
Purdue hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here